We have new job numbers and they're pretty
ugly, quite frankly.
So before the start of the Corona virus pandemic,
the U.S. had about one hundred and fifty eight
million people working.
Now, you probably have heard Republicans bragging
about how more people were working before
the Corona virus pandemic than ever before.
And that's true.
But also, more people were not working before
the coronavirus pandemic than ever before.
This is a very popular political football
that I want to remind you of before we move
on to the data, which is the U.S. population
grows.
So if you have roughly the same portion of
the population working and not working at
almost any point in time, you can accurately
say we have more people than ever working
or you can accurately say we have more people
than ever not working.
Both are often true because the population
keeps getting bigger when it's a Democratic
president.
The Republicans focus on the number of people
not working.
When it's a Republican president, they focus
on the number of people working.
It's a meaningless statistic.
Absent population growth sort of rates.
And that is where that talking point comes
from.
But needless to say, one hundred and fifty
eight million people were working prior to
the start of the Corona virus pandemic.
We now have a total of at least twenty two
point three million people who have lost their
jobs.
Today we learned that another five and a quarter
million people filed for unemployment benefits
last week.
We get the data on a one week delay.
So today we learned about the numbers from
last week.
This brings the total to about 21 million
people who have filed for unemployment benefits
since the start of the Corona virus pandemic.
This is 13 percent of the working population
that have lost their jobs.
And the the real number is even higher.
And what I mean by that is there are systems
at the state level for filing for unemployment
benefits that are over the max.
They are stretched.
They are overwhelmed phone systems where it's
just busy.
They can't even put you in the hold queue.
Web systems that are just crashing because
of the number of people trying to file benefits.
So this is the number of people that have
been able to file benefits.
You've got all the people who have tried but
failed.
You also have people working in under the
table jobs who do not qualify for employment.
Unemployment benefits traditionally, even
if exceptions have been made so that they
do in this particular case.
Many of them don't know it and they've simply
lost their jobs and not even filed.
So the real rate is much higher.
Now we have a situation where the unemployment
rate, as we typically see it.
This is called the U-3 rate.
It's going to be almost useless very soon.
And I'll explain why the U3 is going to go
up, because tens of millions of people have
lost their jobs, but it's likely to go up
only a fraction of the sort of real unemployment
rate.
For this reason and it's counterintuitive,
you might think if 13 percent of the workforce
lost its job, how is it that the unemployment
rate might only go from like four to six or
four to seven percent?
It doesn't make sense.
The way our system works, the U3, which is
that rate that is publicized, though, it's
3.8, it's 4.2.
When you aren't looking for work, you are
no longer considered unemployed from the purposes
of the unemployment rate.
This has always been the case.
And you know, during Obama, as usual, as the
unemployment rate went down, you had Republicans
say the system is bogus.
If you stop looking for work, you're no longer
considered unemployed.
That's been the case for decades.
So, again, it's another distraction technique
that the right loves to use.
But in this particular very special situation,
there are going to be millions of people who
have just lost their jobs, who are not looking
for work, because normally when you file for
benefits, you have a questionnaire to fill
out or you might be doing it online, you might
be answering it on the phone and you are asked,
are you looking for work?
Have you interviewed anywhere for work?
Give us a list of where you have it.
You need to do that in order to get benefits.
If you don't say that you're doing that, you
don't get the benefits because so many of
the current job losses are pandemic related
job losses.
That is not required.
You are not required to be looking for work.
You're only required to be keeping in touch
with your employer.
So this could create a very confusing situation
where despite 22 million people, 21 million
people losing their jobs, we may only see
a couple point uptick in the official unemployment
rate because that's the way the unemployment
rate is calculated.
Republicans would complain about this during
Obama's term.
They'd say the economy is much worse than
the rate tells you because all these people
are so sick of looking for work in this terrible
Obama economy, which wasn't true, that they've
stopped looking.
And so really the the U-3 is inaccurately
low.
That's true.
But that's always the case here.
This.
Really matters because you are not required
to be looking for work to receive unemployment
benefits.
And then there's the issue of the real number
is way higher overwhelmed unemployment systems.
As I mentioned, people trying to file claims
but unable to.
People who have lost jobs where they traditionally
don't get unemployment benefits.
So the true number, sadly, is way higher than
21 million people now.
In real terms, how many of these 21 million
jobs are going to reappear as the pandemic
starts to fade?
The answer is we don't know.
Number one, when we talk about the pandemic
fading, there's not going to be one day where
we flip a switch.
It's gonna be a process.
It's a process that could take up to 18 months
in some ways, shapes or forms.
One report said four restaurants, for example.
July is going to be the limit for a lot of
restaurants.
At which point many restaurant owners will
just start walking away from their leases
and not planning to reopen.
Really, really sad because yesterday was the
record death rate, the number of deaths, rather,
in both the United States and globaly.
So we are not exactly at a time where we should
be planning to reopen, despite Donald Trump
announcing yesterday that today he would give
a list of states that he wants to see reopen
right away.
One other data point, just out of curiosity,
we did a survey of our own audience and we
asked, has your income decreased due to Corona
virus?
Almost two thirds of our audience says they
are.
Their income is the same or higher during
the virus.
Eleven percent saw their income decrease anywhere
from 10 to 30 percent.
Nine percent said their income is down 40
to 70 percent.
Three percent said their income is down 80
to 90 percent.
But 14 percent of our viewers and listeners
say their income dropped to zero.
Notice that 14 percent of our audience has
lost all their income.
It looks like 13 percent of the workforce
nationally has gone on unemployment benefits.
So very similar numbers.
Numbers tracking very similarly there.
So we've got a big uphill battle to get back
to where we were.
Industries may change discussions of nationalizing
certain supply chains are already starting,
whether it's masks or medical equipment or
whatever, because of the virus.
Anybody pretending to know what the economic
landscape is going to look like in 18 months
is simply guessing.
And we need to understand that we need to
sit with the uncertainty because we really
don't have another choice.